what a Vegas Suntory days me and you  free drinks they could be true this is  gonna be all right here dog is gonna be  much let's get some jams going up in  this [ __ ] right now  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  sweet I was growing up my shoulders  almost stronger much longer now what the  hell don't turn it off just cuz you  don't know it what we're gonna do when  we get to Vegas no no no change the  subject about what we're gonna do in  Vegas if you don't know the words just  admit you don't know the little words I  told you why would I make up that I know  don't know that's ridiculous man  no I know the word seems like you didn't  know the word I know the word eight  listen hey listen to me man what what I  know the words that everybody knows okay  no no it's not okay because you  obviously don't believe me hey dude on  our friendship I know the words  I'm sorry so hey just let it go I'm  sorry that's stupid stupid  [Music]  yeah  you